Guten Abend. Ilkis ist mein Name. Heute bin ich die Sustente der ISN auf dieser Station und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Amnesia gespäft führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Bescheid sprechen, brauche ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre Personie heran.
Wie heißt sie denn?
Ich bin Gerda Katz.
Katz?
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nach- und Vornamen, wo ich da werde?
Der Nachname ist Katz, wie die Katze, K-A-T-Z.
Ja.
Und der Vorname ist Gerda, G-E-R-D-A.
Frau Katz oder?
Frau Katz ja.
Wie heißt sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12.07.1968.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Wo ich wiege 72 Kilometer.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68.
Danke Frau Katz. Was führt Sie zu uns? Was kann Ihnen für Sie tun?
Ja, Sie haben einen schlimmen Husten.
Ja, das wird halt immer schlimmer.
Und ich fühle mich, also seit gestern fühle ich mich ganz schlecht.
Ich habe immer solche Schmerzen.
Die ganze Brust tut mir weh, wenn ich husten muss.
Und auch beim Atmen tut es schon weh.
Und ich habe auch heute Nacht total geschwitzt und ich habe dann auch mal Fieber gemessen.
Ich hatte über 39 Temperatur.
Und ich fühle mich so krank und ja, ich bin ganz schlapp.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich gehe gleich ins Krankenhaus.
Mein Mann hat mich netterweise, hat mich hierher gebracht.
Ich hätte überhaupt gar nichts selber kommen können.
Ja, und ja, ich, mir ist ganz schlecht, ja.
Okay, Frau Katz, wo sind Sie genau Ihre Schmerzen?
Im ganzen Brust?
Ja, die ganze Brust tut mir eigentlich weh.
Ja, also, das fängt hier oben an, aber das geht auch bis runter, bis so, wo die Rippen sind.
Ja, das tut alles weh.
Und ich bin schon ganz erschöpft vom vielen Husten.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Dass die Schmerzen so schlimm sind, ist eigentlich erst seit gestern.
Aber der Husten ist schon seit ein paar Tagen.
Und das ist so ein fieser Husten, also mit so ganz viel Schleim, der rauskommt, ja.
Okay.
Und strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo aus?
Ja, der ganze Brustkopf, also so weiter sonst nicht,
aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass der ganze Brustkopf mir weh tut, ja.
Okay.
Wie stank sind Ihre Schmerzen auch eine Schmerzskolle,
wobei ein leichter Schmerz, sind unerträgliche Schmerzen?
Ja, unerträglich ist das natürlich nicht, aber schön ist das auch nicht.
Also vielleicht über die Hälfte, so bei 6 vielleicht.
Und könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Druck und Stumpf oder stelle Schmerzen?
Also es ist sowohl ein Druck als auch so ein Brennen eigentlich.
Druck und Brenn.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne jetzt unser Gespräch für kurze Zeit unterbrechen
und Sie anderen Monate anschließen
und Ihre Wichterparameter wie Atemproben,
Blutdruck und Sauerstoff, Setigung, zu messen.
Und ich würde auch eine EKG schreiben.
Ja.
Ja, das wäre sicherlich ganz gut, ja.
Okay.
Und wie können Ihnen auch für kurze Zeit Sauerstoff geben?
Das wäre vielleicht ganz gut, ja.
Ich hatte mich schon das Gefühl, dass ich nicht gut Luft bekomme, ja.
Okay.
Jetzt machen wir weiter.
Und Frau Katz, Sie haben seit ein paar Tagen Pusten mit Asfurt.
Wie sieht Ihr Asfurt aus?
Ja, am Anfang war das so, wie immer so heller Schleim,
aber jetzt ist es so zunehmend so gelblich-grünlich.
Gelblich-grünlich.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Atemnach?
Ja, also insbesondere in der Nacht war das ganz schlimm.
Da hatte ich das Gefühl, ich musste mich dändig aufsetzen
und versuchen abzuusten.
Und jetzt habe ich auch das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht so sehr gut Luft kriege, ja.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, was Ihr Pusten oder Schmerzen lindert,
das schmerzt?
Ja, also wie gesagt, in der Nacht beim Liegen war es nicht so gut.
Dann habe ich mich zwischendurch mal aufgesetzt.
Ich habe dann ein bisschen, was heißt es, getrunken.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl, das tut so ein bisschen gut,
aber richtig viel besser geworden ist es davon auch nicht.
Und was ich merke, dass ich eigentlich nicht so richtig tief einnahm.
Ich atme nur so ganz oberflächlich.
Okay.
Wie viel Kisten benutzt du zum Schlafen?
Ja, normal habe ich mein normales Kissen.
Ja, aber ich habe das Bett so ein bisschen hochgestellt.
Mein Kopfteil kann ich so hochstellen.
Und dann ging es ein klein wenig besser.
Aber wenn das so, wenn dann richtig so ein Husten-Anfall war,
dann musste ich mich hinsetzen im Bett
und auf die Bettkante setzen und erstmal in Ruhe husten, ja.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas Eingelungen?
Ja, ich hatte noch Hustentropfen zu Hause.
Ich habe auch immer ACC im Haus.
Das habe ich dann genommen.
Aber sehr hat es überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Kennen Sie die Namen der Hustentrofe?
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen, wie das heißt.
Okay.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen bei Belastung oder in Ruhe auch?
Oder nur beim Atmen?
Also insbesondere beim Husten und beim Atmen.
Wenn ich ganz still sitze, geht es vielleicht.
Aber da ich ja ständig husten muss,
tut es eben eigentlich auch ständig weh.
Okay.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit jemandem, der ja in der Beschwerde hat,
vielleicht ihre Sochabe oder?
Nein, sonst aus dem Jahr hustet niemand.
Ich habe auch natürlich klar, ich habe auch ein Corona-Test gemacht,
als es anfing mit dem Husten, ja.
Aber der war auch negativ.
Negativ, okay.
Sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Ja, ja, ja, klar.
Wie viele Mal?
Dreimal.
Wann war die letzte
Nacht über 39 Jahre?
Wo haben Sie das wir über gemessen?
In der Achselöle?
Ja.
Okay.
Bleiben Sie unter Schütteprost?
Schluftrost, nie.
Also, als ich heute Nacht so geschwitzt habe, ja,
da habe ich das gemerkt,
dass sie mir damit einmal kalt wurde.
Sonst schluftrost eigentlich nicht.
Okay. Hatten Sie früher in der Beschwerde?
Ja, also, husten hatte ich natürlich schon häufiger in meinem Leben.
Jeder hat mal husten, aber das ist so schlimm ist,
und das ist so weh tut, das kenne ich überhaupt nicht, ja.
Kommt der husten wie Azake?
Nein, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen,
das ist eigentlich so ständig, ja.
So ständig.
Also, wo es ganz schlimm ist,
war es eben ja besonders schlimm, da hatte ich so das Gefühl,
dass mich das auch am Schlafen total gehindert hat.
Und ganz schlimm war es auch,
ich habe ein bisschen was gegessen,
und nach dem Essen hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich kann überhaupt nicht aufhören zu husten.
Und jetzt habe ich auch nicht besonders viel gegessen heute.
Okay, haben Sie Übelkeit oder Adressen?
Nein, das nicht. Nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser,
lassen Sie mal da ein bisschen gang?
Nein, nein, nein.
Sie meinen jetzt aktuell?
Nein.
Ja, aktuell.
Okay.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie in der letzten Woche Erkältung?
Nein, ich finde,
in der letzten Woche.
Ja, so ein bisschen erkältet ist man ja in dieser Jahreszeit immer, ja.
Es ist so unangenehm draußen,
so nass kalt, und ja, da hat es wahrscheinlich angefangen, ja.
Erst hat so ein bisschen im Hals gekratzt,
und dann habe ich halt die Hüsten bekommen.
Und dann ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schmerzen im Hals?
Oder wie der Name gefühlt?
Ja, so ein Halskratzen, so ein bisschen,
ja, aber der Husten ist schmerz,
und dann ist es so,
so ein bisschen, ja, aber der Husten ist schlimmer als die Halsschmerzen.
Schlimmer. Okay, ich verstehe das.
Hat sich Ihre, wie wie ich Ihnen das seit verandert?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht gewogen,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass sich da irgendwas geändert hat.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben heute nicht gut gegessen.
Ja, die letzten Tage war das nicht so doll.
Ich hatte überwiegend, wollte ich etwas Warmes trinken,
ich habe viel Tee getrunken,
und dann habe ich mir meine Suppe gemacht,
aber richtig gut gegessen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Weil ich auch immer so verschluckte, ich verschluck mich vielleicht, oder so.
Okay. Haben Sie Schluckprobleme?
Nein, das einig nicht,
aber weil ich halt ständig so husten muss.
Okay. Haben Sie Herzprobleme,
Herzrasen, Herzgluck und Benet?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Katz.
Und Sie haben natürlich Schluckprobleme wegen uns.
Ja, ja, nachts habe ich, ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe überhaupt nicht geschlafen,
aber ein bisschen zwischendurch muss ich geschlafen haben.
Ja, okay. Und Sie haben Möglichkeit?
Ja, jetzt klar, jetzt bin ich ein bisschen kaputt.
Okay. Und haben Sie eine doerhafte Krankheit,
Bluthochdruck, Blutzschluckkrankheit oder andere?
Ja, ich bin ja Betägerin, ja,
aber also nicht schon von Jugend an,
sondern eigentlich jetzt erst seit,
wie lange hat es das her, dass man das festgestellt hat.
Schon, ja, es ist schon zehn Jahre her, ja.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie Medikamente dagegen?
Ja, ich nehme Medformin regelmäßig ein.
Medformin, wie viel Milligramm?
Ja, tausend, einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Okay. Und andere Krankheiten?
Ein bisschen Blutdruck habe ich noch, ja, das ist ja,
und das hat man so fünf Jahren,
ist das ungefähr festgestellt worden.
Und seither nehme ich Ramepril zweimal am Tag.
Und kennen Sie die Dosierung für Ramepril?
Nein, das ist Ramepril zehn, was da draufsteht, ja.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal auf Reden vorne?
Ja, als Kind habe ich nicht die Mandekosche Blinter am rausbekommen.
Blinter. Wann war das?
Da war ich so in der dritten Klasse, so acht, neun Jahre alt.
Okay. Das war die einzige Operation.
Ja, sonst bin ich noch nicht operieren worden, ne?
Okay. Und sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Sie haben Corona-Impfung und gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Sind Sie geimpft?
Ja, seinerzeit gegen Kinderkrankheiten bin ich natürlich geimpft worden
gegen alles, was es so gibt, ja.
Okay. Und gegen Grippe?
Ja, Grippe-Impfung wollte ich schon machen, habe ich aber noch nicht in diesem Jahr.
Nicht in diesem Jahr, okay.
War das in Nesterzeit im Ausland?
Ja, in dem Ausland bin ich nicht gewesen, nein.
Okay. Frau Katz, haben Sie allergin oder unter Trittigkeit?
So viel, ich weiß. Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergisch bin.
Nein, okay.
Und jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familie ein bisschen.
Gibt es Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter ist relativ früh gestorben, die lebt nicht mehr.
Die hat Brustkrebs gehabt.
Aber mein Vater lebt noch und da weiß ich eigentlich nur,
dass der ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck hat,
sonst geht es nicht ganz gut für sein Alter.
Okay. Wie alt war Ihre Mutter, als Sie gestorben sind?
Ja, da waren Sie so 74, so etwas rum.
74?
Aber Sie sind Geschwester?
Ich habe keine Geschwester, nein.
Ja, okay. Sie sind ein, sie sind Kinder.
Okay. Aber Sie sind Kinder?
Ja, ich habe Kinder, aber sie sind schon erwachsen, ne?
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich bin sehr gesund.
Okay. Frau, wie ist Ihre Familie in der Stadt?
Meine Familie ist sehr lieb.
Ich habe gesagt, ich bin verheiratet, weil man hat nicht eine Erwaltung.
Entschuldigung, ja.
Und lebt Sie mit Ihrem Mann zusammen?
Ja, ja, klar.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite beim Finanzamt, da bin ich angestellt.
Okay. Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Hm, auch, ich würde mal sagen, ne, eigentlich Stress über dich,
habe ich da nicht mehr.
Bekommen Sie Ihre Periode, oder Sie sind schon im Wechsel?
Ja, ich bin schon im Wechsel, ja.
Es ist schon ein paar Jahre, drei Jahre mindestens, ja.
Aber ich gereglehmne Sie zur Kripsvorsorge natürlich.
Ja, okay.
Ja, auch allein wegen meiner Mutter, ne?
Und zur Mammografie zum Screening gehe ich auch immer hin.
Ja, das war sehr schön.
Okay, Frau Katz, ich habe keine Weite bepragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich will nicht nur noch mit mich irgendwo hinlegen
und mich auch nicht ausruhen, weil ich so kaobin von der Hosterei
und ich bin total erschöpft, ja.
Entschuldigung, ich möchte nur eine Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Beine schwällingen bemerkt?
Schwällingen in Ihrem Bein bemerkt?
Nein, warum sollen die Beine schwällen?
Nein, nein, ich habe Husten, nein, mit den Beinen, da ist nichts.
Okay, danke schön.
Zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Danach besprechen ich Ihren Fall mit meinem Oberarzt
und dann komme ich zurück und teile Ihnen mit, was zu tun ist.
Ja, und kann ich mich so lange irgendwo ein bisschen ausruhen?
Ja, und noch für ein paar Minuten und dann untersuche ich Sie.
Untersuchen Sie mich, gut.
Vielen Dank, sehr schön, 18 Minuten.
18 Minuten, Sie haben auch gepasst, ja.
Haben unsere Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Das war wieder sehr vollständig, ne?
Ja, ich denke sehr vollständig.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Doch, ich gucke.
Haben Sie eine Bewusstsein, die die Regierungsminderung bemerkt?
Was ist Regierungsminderung?
Also haben Sie eine verminderte Regierungsminderung.
Sie müssen mir sagen, was Vigilanz ist.
Ich bin ja kein Arzt.
Ja, veranderte Bewusstsein, so etwas.
Also Bewusstsein habe ich nicht verloren
und ich kann auch klar denken, wenn ich nicht so müde wäre, ja,
könnte ich noch klarer denken.
Okay.
Und zweite Frage ist, atmen Sie schneller als sonst?
Ja, klar, weil ich auch nur so ganz flach atmen kann,
sonst tut es hier so weh.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe Noxen.
Ist hier noch was eingefallen?
Ja, Noxen.
Ach, stimmt, ja.
Und Noxen haben Sie gar nicht abgefallen,
das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen, ja.
Gut, also, ich bin aber nicht draufholt.
Okay.
Ich habe noch Fragen, Kollegen.
Ich habe keine weitere Frage.
Vigilanz minder, ich habe mehr Aufmerksamkeit.
Ja.
Könnten wir als als Geschäfte anfangen?
Frau Irgans?
Ja, ich habe keine.
Von ihr aus können wir.
Von mir aus immer.
Ja, ich muss nicht viel tun.
Guten Abend, liebe Frau Wersten.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Darf ich?
Aber ja, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Es geht um Frau Gerard Katz.
Sie ist 58 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß, 72 kg schwer.
Wie groß ist sie?
1,78 m.
Okay.
Sie ist bei, sie wurde bei Ihrem Mann zu uns mitgebracht.
Ihr Mann hat sie zu uns begleitet?
Ja, begleitet.
Sie ist in ganz Torax und würde in die Unterrippen ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzinterestät liegt bei 8, in Entschuldigung 6 von uns.
Und die Schmerzcharakterität sei rückende und brennende Schmerz.
Die Schmerzcharakterität.
Die Patientin hat ihre Körpertemperatur gestern Abend und heute Morgen in der Achse gemessen.
Das war im Gestern Abend 39 Grad.
Heute war das unter 39.
Sie klackt über 8 Dispnoe und
die Taktübne.
Die Frage nach Taktikardi und Falkitation wurden per night.
Sie haben gegen Husten und ACS eingenommen.
Sie haben viel warme Krenke getrunken, aber diese haben ihr nicht geholfen.
Sie haben selbst Corona Testgemacht. Das war negativ.
Sie haben keine Liktion oder Defekation Probleme und keine Beine.
Als vegetative Anamnese haben sie in Appetenz und Schmerzbeding Husten benigt.
Sie müssen das Bett hochstellen zum Schlafen.
Sie haben die Frage nach Neuse überkauft.
Als für Erkrankungen haben sie seit 10 Jahren Diabetes meleutastypt 2 und seit 5 Jahren Aterelektrikartoni.
Besonders der Medikament nehmen sie regelmäßig mit Formen 1 Gramm, 2 Mal täglich
und mit Formen 2 Gramm, 10 Milligramm.
Als für Operationen wurde eine Epandemie bei ihr mit 8 bis 9 Jahren durchgeführt.
Der Impfstatus sei vollständig.
Sie haben nicht geimpft.
Die Reise Anamnese ist unabhängig.
Sie kann keine Allergien oder Unterrechtlichkeiten bei ihr bekannten.
Sie ist nicht traurig.
Über Alkohol und Drogenkonsum wurde ich keine Frage gestellt.
Hab ich keine Fragen gestellt?
Hab ich keine Fragen gestellt.
Nach diesem Gespräch werde ich beide die Körperlöhne untersuchen.
Laut der Familie Anamnese haben die Diabetes-Arterielektrikartoni die Mutter sei an Brustkrebs mit 74 Jahren gestorben.
Sie haben eine Schwester und sie haben zwei Geschenste.
Was vermuten Sie jetzt?
Ich habe einen Verdach auf Pynomonie.
Was könnte es der Verlustreildiagnost sein?
Ich möchte die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Besonders Lungen-Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ausgutieren?
Ausgutieren.
Ich beurteile die Atem, Tachypne und die Zeichen für Disziplinole, Pilazianose und auch Torax-Bewegungen.
Bei der Palpation ist die Erwartung der Gedäffte klug.
Bei Abhörten?
Bei Abhörten höre ich die Atm- und Rasselgeräusche.
Und Labo-Untersuchungen, Blutbild, Differenzialblutbild, Essündung, Parameter und operative Diagnostik.
Ich werde einen Röschkern Torax in zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage zur Labo-Untersuchung.
Was bietet sich der noch so an?
Die Blut-Kultur, Blutgasanalyse.
Haben Sie noch mal einen Nasenrachenabstrich gemacht?
Ich werde auch wieder Nasenrachenabstrich für Corona und Schinalinflasertests.
Torax in zwei Ebenen.
Was wäre der nächste Schritt?
Das machen Sie therapeutisch mit der Patientin, wenn sie tatsächlich eine Diagnostik hat?
Mit Hilfe der CRB-5.6-Kritzerin können wir entscheiden ob die Patient ambulant oder stationär behandelt wird.
Das heißt, der Patient hat keine Konfusion.
Atemfrequenz, wenn Atemfrequenz mehr als 30 ist, ist ein Punkt.
Blutdruck, wenn der Patient Hypoten, wenn der Stolische Druck mehr als 100 ist, ist ein Punkt für diese Kriterien.
Die Patientin ist 56 Jahre alt, das ist weniger als 65.
Wenn wir sich dazu näher aufnehmen, was sind denn die Maßnahmen, die wir machen?
Wenn es ist, dann sind es auch Flüssigkeit und Antibioteterapie, Analyse.
Und gegebenenfalls?
Dass Sie hier schon Unterwegs gegeben haben?
Ja, das war richtig.
Dann bin ich gespannt, was Sie mir über Frau Katz erzählen.
Machen Sie erst die Untersuchung und dann sprechen wir noch einmal.
Wenigstens musste ich jetzt nicht mehr husten.
Gut, ja, ich sag mal, so 2 Teilungen war auch ein bisschen ausgeprägt.
An am Nese war ein bisschen flüssiger als der Bericht.
Sprachlich, was mir beim Bericht aufgefallen ist, dass Sie wirklich auch relativ häufig machen.
Oftmals hinter jedem zweiten Wort.
Das ist sowas, was man natürlich ganz schwer ausmerzen kann, wenn man sich das erstmal angewöhnt hat.
Es hilft einem ja auch immer, so ein bisschen Zeit zu gewinnen.
Wir machen das ja alle, aber eben bei Ihnen ist es schon ziemlich ausgeprägt gewesen.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Einmal gab es eine kleine Differenz bei den Zahlen.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, sie ist 1,68 groß und sie haben sie 10 cm größer gemacht.
Sie haben also immer als Astro, sie haben 1,78 gesagt.
Und dann haben sie sich aber nachher, hatten wir einmal genau 8 von 10, haben sie erst gesagt
und haben sich aber noch korrigiert.
Es waren nur 6 von 10, die Schmerzgala.
Was ist mir noch aufgefallen?
Im Fragenkatalog, da habe ich heute Morgen mit einer Kollegin von Ihnen trainiert
und wir sind auf die gute Lösung gekommen, dass man eben um dieses ständige haben, haben, haben, haben sie
zu vermeiden, dass man stattdessen sehr gut indirekte Fragen stellen kann.
Dass man sagt, nun möchte ich von Ihnen noch wissen,
ja, was weiß ich, welche, wie Ihre Schmerzqualität ist.
Ja, jetzt habe ich noch einige Fragen zu Ihrer familiären Situation.
Können Sie mir sagen, ob Ihre Eltern noch leben oder ob Ihre Eltern schwere Krankheiten haben?
Ja, ich möchte auch noch gerne wissen, ob bei Ihnen irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen bestehen.
Ja, das ist schön, wenn man das so ein bisschen variiert, dass das nicht so dieser Fragenkatalog ist,
der so runtergefragt wird.
Das macht es ein bisschen interessanter
und hält den Patienten auch so ein bisschen bei Ihnen, weil Sie ja sagen, ich möchte von Ihnen noch was wissen.
Können Sie mir etwas sagen?
Dann sind Sie so im direkten Dialog und er hat nicht so das Gefühl, er wird so abgefragt.
Ja, also Diagnosetherapie war klar, haben Sie logisch gut gelöst und Diagnose stimmt natürlich.
Was ich nicht weiß, wie das tatsächlich gehandhabt wird in der echten Prüfungssituation,
wenn Sie sagen, ich unterbreche das Gespräch und mache jetzt erstmal Untersuchungen,
ob Sie das dann hinterher auch berichten, dass Sie dann praktisch im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch sagen,
ich habe bei der Patientin bereits ein EKG gemacht, Sauerstoffsetigung und ihr Vitalparameter eben überprüft.
Genau genommen erwartet dann ja der Oberarzt oder der Gesprächspartner bereits Befunde,
die Sie aber natürlich in der Gesprächssituation nicht haben.
Ich weiß nicht, kann mir jemand helfen, wie wird es gehandhabt in der Prüfung echt?
Ach so, die kriegt man dann dazu. Das ist natürlich spannend, ja, denn sonst muss man sich ja irgendwas selber überlegen,
wie krank ist denn der Patient jetzt, ja, und das finde ich so ein bisschen schwierig,
aber auf alle Fände meine ich sollte man das erwähnen.
Ich habe schon die Untersuchung gemacht, denn das würde sonst ja der Oberarzt nachfragen oder die Oberarzt sagen,
haben Sie denn schon Sauerstoffsetigung zum Beispiel gemessen? Hat die schon ein bisschen O2 gekriegt?
Und das macht ja auch Sinn, dass man das dann auch mitberichtet.
Gut, ja, also der Bericht war nicht ganz so flüssig, ich meine beim letzten Mal war irgendwie ein bisschen flotter,
aber vielleicht habe ich das auch falsch in der Erinnerung, es war ein bisschen mehr stockend,
aber im Anamnesebereich fand ich es erstmal sehr komplett, habe das natürlich nicht gemerkt, dass die Noxen nicht gefragt haben,
aber ja, gut, wollte ich Ihnen jetzt auch nicht unbedingt, also habe ich nicht gemerkt
und es ist auch unauffällig eigentlich bei der Patientin, insofern hat es jetzt nicht viel Konsequenzen gehabt,
aber das würde Ihnen natürlich in der Prüfung übel genommen werden, das gebe ich zu dir, da sollten Sie das auf keinen Fall vergessen.
Gut, ja, also ein bisschen besser sortieren im Arztgespräch und versuchen,
versuchen diese Sprachliche, diese Ästchen ein bisschen zu vermeiden
und dann haben wir es aber, glaube ich, ja, das ist meine Manöverkritik für Sie, ja?
Ja, gut.